some people they try too [ __ ] hard to
hold on to family that is toxic because
they're like nah man
we're family we gotta [ __ ] do it but
there's just some people that you just
gotta get rid of man
yep for me there was I mean it's a whole
long story I'm gonna go too much into it
but there was a point I didn't talk to
my dad for a whole year so when I was
trying to be a stand-up comic and do
music and everything else like that my
dad and I did not get along number one
there could be a numerous reasons for it
and understandably I understand where he
comes from too because you know I wasn't
that great of a kid so maybe he was
trying to he was trying to set up a
future for me but I don't want to follow
it but what ended up happening was I
would snap at him he would snap at me I
was napping and he would snap at me and
I remember at a certain point I felt so
[ __ ] defeated I just asked my mom
what am I supposed to do around dad like
how do we get along cuz as of right now
like I feel he hates me and I hate him
she goes you know what just you need to
talk to him in a calm manner speak to
him kindly and just say yes just for now
while you live under his house just say
yes I said cool I'm gonna try this out
so and you gotta fight every 30 sec this
[ __ ] out so this is was like my last
straw so I basically basically what
happened was I I went to Bible study
came back but when I left the Bible
study I I broke this door it was like I
lived in this in the back in the
backyard in this shed area we call it
the shed but it was actually just a
separate house area that's where I lived
I my dad built that so I was living
there but it was so hot this summer I
was like 110 degrees at the wood kind of
warped and it locked me in that in that
room so I had a break out and so the
latch broke the cool a man lived in the
backyard Shack yeah basically we call it
the shed but the shed it wasn't really
sure that it had a see oh so it's like
another hope with that house yeah cool
okay
yeah and so I broke that [ __ ] and I went
went out and I kind of just left it
there I mean I had nothing I mean what
can I do and it was in the yard and the
yard skated out so I came back and my
dad got home before I did and he goes
why the hell did you break the door
below about what were you thinking and I
was like okay debt and and he called me
and I told him was like hey I'm really
sorry I'll explain to you when I get
back but I'm a Bible study right now so
can
just wait and he starts screaming at the
top of his lungs and I was just like the
[ __ ] that I lost hell he's not working
you know and I was like I'm sorry I said
started multiple times and I said I'll
be back and we'll talk about it so come
back home and the first thing he did was
like he called me he was like why are
you so stupid is what he said
and I looked at him and so years ago I
had a conversation with him I told him
to stop calling me stupid I was like if
you call me dumb one more time like I
will literally leave and you will never
speak to me ever again
and that's the thing my mom always told
him was to never call a stupid and can
he call me stupid again
yeah and that [ __ ] [ __ ] enraged me
and I was like that means he's stupid
because he didn't even want to listen so
he's he's so interesting because I he
goes like I remember him yelling he goes
like wow he was when you need help why
don't you just call me I was like dude I
was locked in that place the a/c was but
I would have died we're done talking
about right and I and I remember because
I was just trying not to yell so I was
just staying calm because I was trying
to take my mom's advice so you didn't
even get to explain that you couldn't
get out I couldn't explain it he was
just like yelling at you yeah why would
you do that Bubba I was like well the
door he just kept yelling over me
yelling yelling yelling yelling and it
we got into this whole fiasco where
basically he got so confrontational I
actually just [ __ ] shut past him and
I and I literally are Glassdoor I
[ __ ] like Muay Thai taped that [ __ ]
and his [ __ ] collapsed it fell
forward I went to the back when Sam and
I grabbed my [ __ ] and I laugh at this
age you're already too big so he
couldn't beat your ass yeah he I was
just too big but you know I never ever
fought back so it's like you would [ __ ]
his perimeters punch the wall oh you
have terrible hand eye coordination my
face all right
you missed me again [ __ ] yes so
basically what happened like just to
keep that long story short I left we had
we had a point where I talked to him and
I was like hey man like you you were I
told him he was wrong I was like you
were wrong right but he's never wrong
yeah and my mom knew he was wrong and he
was wrong and he couldn't control his
temper he was yelling at me he called me
dumb and you know my mom knew she was
really upset at him and I say stupid in
Korea well he called me [ __ ] come
she elope yes I've heard that so
yeah Japanese but I remember cuz he was
I he after I left and I came back I went
to get some more of my stuff he was just
screaming in the room and I you know I
was outside the his door and I was just
standing there and I said - when he
finally quieted down I was like and when
I said to him verbatim was if you are
telling me right now you didn't do
anything wrong
since the day I was born you've never
messed up once in your life that you and
I can never have a relationship right
and then he said I've never done a
single thing wrong to you
and I that's already wrong in the
statement it was like a posit and he
said that was like cool and I literally
grabbed my [ __ ] and I left I didn't talk
to him for a year my mom was like
bawling and whatever but he just
wouldn't admit that he was wrong and
that was like a plane was like I can
talk to Hubbard and dog yes
stubborn and so why are pastors so
stubborn ancient Asian dad pests are so
[ __ ] stubborn it's like he's not like
that anymore it has to do with either
his youth or something it could be just
frustration from other stuff
relationship [ __ ] money
mm-hmm raising - [ __ ] crazy what
crazy kid well okay he that's why your
brother's his little angel my my dad my
mom I remember my mom had a conversation
with my dad and I found this after the
fact but my mom told me that he had a
conversation with them where he had this
dream where he wanted his family to be
in one household because he grew up in a
broken household - because he but he
broke the house so my mom would say that
she goes you should feel bad for your
father because he's probably one of the
saddest human beings I've ever met I
mean I was like because he grew up in a
broken household his house wasn't that
great right but at the same time because
he well he doesn't want that to happen
he's trying to keep you guys as close as
possible but because he's doing that
he's pushing you away so it's it's -
thirsty so it's he says she's it's very
sad yeah he's trying to keep you all
together because he wants this family
unit but because he's doing that he
won't let you breathe so he's pushing
you away and he wants to hold onto you
so hard so she says feel bad for him I
was like I do feel bad but at the same
time
being abused yes you can't call me
stupid and expect me to stay around and
she talked to him she goes you know you
have arguably number one she goes your
if you wanted him to be this Korean
Korean kid
we should have lived in Korea hmm why
did you move us here see was that was
your choice you chose to raise a Korean
American kid if you wanted a Korean
Korean kid where you live in this
household and there's generational
family stuff then we should have stayed
in Korea so you have to live with that
choice so David's an American kid what
did you want damn
my mom said the same [ __ ] dude you're
not smart yeah and so she she and I
think that kind of hit my dad a little
bit he goes oh David he's not gonna be
the kid that I want him to be I said of
course not like what did you think and
and so at that point he even apologized
after a year you know how I came back
into the house he calls me up he goes I
have a new puppy you want to tell your
little black and white water you say
sorry yeah
Jasmine yes I want to go see the puppy
and we play with the puppy and then he
was just like she should probably just
move back in you should probably back in
I cleaned up the shed it's nice that you
can just move back in there I was like
is he saying sorry all right
baby steps baby's good to be are you
past the point of like asking your
father like how it was for him because
if your mom had to explain to you what
it was for your father for him to open
up that conversation to it might be a
little overwhelming but I mean oh I know
what it was like because we had a I
mentioned this before where we had a
huge fight where he actually opened up
and told me it was our last fight ever
it was like four years ago so he our
last fight he basically opened up I said
you know what like you want this I feel
I want to have a relationship with you
like the way you he said that yeah
because I told him I told him I was like
what's true basically we got into it
this thing when I told him like why
can't you just talk to me like a person
I was like I call our mom two three
times a week because we just talk hey
what are you doing yeah oh I'm just
doing this [ __ ] blah blah blah we joke
around you know every time you call me
it's what are you doing are you doing
this right are you doing this wrong yeah
why can't you just talk to me like a
person you're the one who wants to be
close to me but I haven't had a
conversation with you ever right and he
just goes you goes you know I can't do
that because
my parents didn't talk to me like that
my mom didn't your grandma your grandpa
didn't talk to me like that I didn't
talk to them like that I had a girl
about to take care of them so for me
this is how I communicate this is the
only way I know how to so you say you're
trying to change me you keep trying to
change me and making me into this new
guy but I can't this is how I am so I'm
at this point I'm 60 years old who are
you trying to change because you should
be at the point where you're trying to
understand me and change for me I was
like oh well [ __ ] you know and I was
like you should understand this is how I
communicate so how come you can't do the
same thing back for me and I was like oh
[ __ ] he thought he got my ass there
mm-hmm
and so now I just oh [ __ ] and I kind of
was like oh I get it now but it's cool
cuz he's kind of meaning to fall like
[ __ ] it's hard man
yeah I've been talking to people like
like a [ __ ] leader yeah so what did
you expect that that's him just saying
I'm concerned for you yeah right he's
like hey little [ __ ] how come you
[ __ ] post this yeah so you know that
YouTube video mmm you don't think you're
uploading enough he's like you know but
that's his way of saying like Oh is
everything all right because you're not
posting yeah are you making enough money
yeah do you need help that's like my mom
sushi we have a rule I made a rule that
I was like you are not allowed to ask me
about YouTube stuff because you don't
know it and I don't know how to explain
it to you so stop asking right but
without fail two minutes later you
should probably post a video right now I
have one for you yeah we transmitted
that's like the only mommy there's
others too but that's like the main time
I had to like cut my dad out yeah that's
really amazing that your father but you
didn't you took a break yeah you didn't
really cut them out no III don't know if
I'll be able to cut cut family out like
I'm not like that though well you don't
have shitty family yeah I mean they help
they would have to do some some [ __ ]
terrible I get like oh okay I had
in-laws that we know well a lot of my
cousin's just don't allow back into the
family anymore because rapists oh that's
pretty bad but no we don't have any
other
so he told us on a podcast about his
uncle who has a little bit of issues
yeah but keep going okay things happened
in my family like we had a very toxic
abusive family and people were like
talking [ __ ] behind each other's backs
and all this stuff right and then we
found the root of the problem